big breaking news is going on right now
and we've got lots to break down in the
context of this the post millennial
reports Twitter's vice president of
trust and safety Ella Irwin reportedly
leaves the company amid daily wire
debacle so this is huge head of Twitter
trust and safeties report reportedly has
resigned a report from Forbes stated
that she's no longer in the top uh in
the Twitter's internal slack Reuters
reporter Sheila dang said that Irwin's
resignation was confirmed now this is a
big story what's going on all right
let's let's get through this tempgas.com
reporting mistake Elon Musk says what is
a woman can stream on Twitter it's
definitely allowed what do we got here
that's uh we have Zero Hedge reporting
on the rumor just before the show
started that she may have left the
company we've got uh film lab this one's
Big Jeremy boring says in a Twitter
space that the Twitter people who
canceled daily wires what is a woman
said Elon Musk was in the room and
approved the cancellation
as of right now
the visibility on Matt Walsh's tweet is
still limited restricted and my
understanding is that what is a woman
which was posted by the daily wire is
still being restricted by Twitter so the
story is the daily wire
planned in coordination with Twitter a
special event page to publish the
documentary what is a woman
at the last minute they were told that
they would not be allowed to run an
event page and that if they post the
documentary it would be labeled hate
speech Unlimited
so Matt Walsh posted the two clips in
question that they demanded be censored
and sure enough those tweets were
restricted and were limited Elon Musk
has come out and said that it's all a
mistake and of course it's allowed but
as of right now what I'm seeing on
Twitter they're still being heavily
limited and if the report is true Jeremy
boring saying that the Twitter people
tell him you know there's a lot a lot of
uh uh hearsay there
some some is going on so the question is
is Elon Musk being forthright when it
comes to this issue
and I'm leaning towards no I like Elon I
think he's doing great work with SpaceX
I can say it a million times but when he
tweeted this was a big mistake and it's
being fixed and it's still not being
fixed I don't necessarily trust Elon
Musk now I'm not saying I don't trust
him just because someone claimed he was
in the room when when daily wire was
confirmed to be banned restricted
doesn't mean he actually was and the
fact that the VP of trust and safety is
has resigned I wonder if what's really
happening is that Elon Musk went in
there and said hey I I don't even know
if he's in SF right now because he was
just in China or something yes he might
have been like what's going on and why
are you doing this and maybe they were
like if you don't block this I quit and
then he probably said then quit and she
said fine so in order for Elon to get in
like I'll just put it this way
I still will get beyond the benefit of
that because he had no reason to tweet
in support of the daily wire when he did
but Ian miles Chong was like it must
suck to be Elon you know you think
everything's going fine you wake up and
everything's on fire and I'm like not
only that but Elon isn't the one who's
doing all of this so all of a sudden
everyone on Twitter is screaming Elon
you've betrayed us and he's like in a
meeting and he comes like what's
happening like dude I'm not even here
right now let me take care of it it's
been only a couple of hours now This
Woman's resigning it sounds like this
resignation shows Elon is taking heavy
action to rectify the problem
okay when I lost my page uh it was like
a month ago or whatever I woke up and I
couldn't log on to Twitter okay reached
out to Tim Tim put something out he's
like Elon Josie can't log on to Twitter
and elon's like oh I'm fixing it he
responded right that was weird yeah
um Ella directly got me my Twitter
account back really directly yep she
directly worked with me to get it back
why so this is so this is important
because your original Twitter account
was mysteriously shut down for no reason
no reason yep for a year and a half yep
but it was right before you made some
prediction or something right it was uh
right after I predicted that Joe Biden
Kamala Harris it was 20 right yeah yeah
so what was that I you tweeted that it
was gonna be Biden Harris yes so I
tweeted that in 20 June January 2019 I
tweeted that it was going to be Biden
Harris it's my pin tweet on my page you
can see it I said it's going to be Biden
Harris this is what it's going to be and
I said that January 2019 and then on the
day of the inauguration I I put it up
there and I said it's gonna this you
know I predicted this has happened and
like within within 10 days my page was
gone just gone I couldn't log in I was
permanently suspended no reason no idea
why it lasted for a year and a half then
Elon Musk on April 26th of last last
year said I'm gonna buy Twitter the next
day I got my account back then recently
you were locked mysterious again and it
was the same exact thing what happened
before but it wasn't like a normal
Banning no it was like I just couldn't
like your pages is gone Paige blanked
out I could there was nothing I couldn't
get into it it was just gone they didn't
know so what is that though with with
what you're saying there this see the
Ella Irwin this surprises me because
she's been pretty good about a lot of
stuff it's the new CEO that I thought
was gonna go so so yeah oh so maybe her
resignation is due to the new CEO they
don't get along it could be something
like that it could be that she resigned
because the people under her did this
and she didn't boss them correctly I I'm
not sure I don't she just seemed really
good so that's why yeah if she was doing
if she was doing right by the users and
as to what Elon wanted and it was
underlings who acted up I'd imagine she
would not resign she would come out and
tweet and be like employees here are
upset and we're telling them no I bet
this is the new CEO
interesting and because I got because
then when she's like elon's yelling at
me I'm not doing this CEO goes I'm the
CEO and I'm telling you to do it she was
I quit I'm done oh that's interesting
has the new CEO taken
yeah yeah if he's not in the country
right now and she's running the company
this is what's going on that's very
interesting that it could have been what
she did immediately like having the
power to do that I mean Twitter's been
slow to change some of the stuff so I
wouldn't be surprised that there's you
know some people at the lower levels
that are still manipulating some of this
stuff like I was I was
censored from Twitter back in December
for saying that gender dysphoria is a
mental illness and I was locked out of
my account and and so but I don't know
if that's been fixed because I still
self-censor myself from saying that
because I don't know if it's going to
block my account again you know check
this out so this is the daily wires
tweet they say it's the movie they
really don't want you to see what is a
woman watch the explosive documentary
starring Matt Walsh blog free on Twitter
for 24 hours and I'm gonna click this uh
just right here we got this little
retweet button it's our little retreat
but I'm gonna click that retweet button
why can't you retweet this we try to
keep Twitter a place for healthy
conversations so we've disabled most of
the ways to engage with this tweet
wow all in the name of being healthy
that tweet is so healthy like I feel
stronger already but yeah this this
still doesn't make any sense because
Elon bought Twitter because the Babylon
B right sparked very much by The Babylon
B misgendering somebody and they're
saying the two scenes were because they
were misgendering can you pull up elon's
absolutely no sense I believe I have
Elon I just want to highlight this real
quick Jeremy boring has quote tweeted
the daily wire saying please share this
in case Twitter indeed throttles it I
have I've retweeted his quote tweet
which allows you to carry to share the
the documentary so I think what is woman
is a very good documentary and I'll tell
you why one of the scenes in question
that was limited Matt Walsh is actually
arguing from the perspective of trans
activists to the shop owner I'm like
he's doing a good job as an interviewer
the interviewer says here's how I feel
about trans people and then Matt Walsh
says but you don't you're not a
scientist like what how do you know and
that he's actually taking the points to
get his his response in reaction to it
he's not just approaching this like we
already have our minds made up and we're
gonna he actually says like hey tell me
what you think I thought that was a very
respectable I think the documentary was
very well done I've seen it twice now
um and what I really like about it
though is Matt didn't put his biases
into it I mean it is it's a bias it's
shaping a narrative into One Direction
but what he does is he goes into these
interviews and just lets the like the
trans activists just talk and they show
you who they are and so he didn't have
to like guide them in any direction and
what Tim's saying is correct and it's
interesting because I actually was um
last fall I was doing an event down in
Richmond I gotta interrupt sorry Elon
just tweeted we're updating the system
tomorrow so that those who follow real
daily wire yes
yep got it so
um I was doing an event last year in
Richmond with no left turn education and
Eventbrite removed that event because we
were doing a screening of what is a
woman followed by a panel discussion
with me
a doctor
um another human rights Advocate and
like so we were having a discussion
about it and it was still Eventbrite
took the event down that's the second
time or that's the first time out of two
that they've done that to me too people
are pointing out that Elon was in
Shanghai so he likely was not in the
room that doesn't make sense and the new
CEO isn't starting for a month or so so
I'm wondering what's happening but take
a look at this elon's basically saying
confirmed censorship on gender issues
Robbie Starbucks tweets despite Elon
Musk promising the real daily wire film
about his woman by Matt Walsh wouldn't
be censored it seems someone at Twitter
staff chose to censor it anyways less
than 20 minutes after it was posted you
can't even comment whoever did this
should be fired Elon says we're updating
the system tomorrow is that those who
follow real daily wire will see this in
their feed but it won't be recommended
to non-followers nor will any any
advertising be associated with it guess
what that's Elon Musk saying we will
Shadow ban your content
do you think this has this has something
to do with the uh the he just pulled out
of the EU agreement which is about to go
into effect next year that's going to
force companies to censor a speech or
not do business in that country I think
you know what I think it is I think Elon
sees Twitter
he sees the Babylon bee getting censored
he's like okay this is messed up he
genuinely is like I'm gonna buy Twitter
I think he has legitimate use for it
with ax that's why it's merged with X I
think he wants this for his One-Stop
Shop app it makes sense to buy add
payment processing and video and stuff
and he genuinely thought he could have
free speech until the powers that be
from the international uh political
leaders came to him and we saw this with
turkey he said he didn't have a choice
with turkey ban some accounts or the
whole app gets banned and then One By
One The Dominoes fall and Elon Musk is
being pushed in the same direction as
Jack Dorsey I don't think he understood
the experiences of Jack Dorsey and why
Jack went this route and now Twitter is
going to end up being the exact same
thing that it was yeah dude thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time